you did some of the most difficult
interviews ever
you have a device
that you can give to someone like me or
anyone hoping to understand something
about a human being
sitting across from them about what it
takes to do a good interview
you're doing one
well no but there's a
listen there's levels to this game
and interviewing somebody like vladimir
putin also language barrier
sit across from the man
tried to keep an open mind
i tried to also ask challenging
questions but not challenging with the
with an agenda but seeking to understand
and understand deeply
how do you do that
seeking the truth it's very simple
seeking the truth being a questioner
like you are you want to know what is
really going on i could not get anywhere
with uh biden or bush or for that matter
obama they'd be opaque with me there's
no interview possible with the president
of the united states because he's got to
stand for all the stuff that they stand
for
which is imperialism which is control of
the world how can you defend that
you can't see no one's going to come out
and say that they're always going to
blame
the enemy they're going to blame iran
they're going to blame china
so some people it may not be possible to
break through the opaque case
i mean have you ever seen an interview
with the president besides being
personable
where he actually discussed american
policy yeah i mean not really but maybe
after their president
i could see obama being able to do such
an interview i could see george w
being able to do such an interview or
are they not able to reflect at all
george w hasn't shown much conscience in
terms of thinking about what he's done
you've seen that it was you ever seen my
movie w
i think that's one of my best movies
because it shows a man who's just out of
his depth
and has no
he has a conscience at the end of the
movie if he if you remember correctly he
talks to his wife and he says
i don't get it i'm trying to do good in
the world i've done i believe in good
and right and why do people
not understand that you know that kind
of complaint as if he can't get outside
himself to understand the way other
people think
empathy walking like a dramatist is what
i do you walk in the f footsteps of
other people
when i did a movie about richard nixon
it wasn't because i liked him it was
because i wanted to
i think i understood a part of him
because my father and i think i wanted
to walk in his footsteps that's not to
say i sympathize with him because i
didn't i don't think he helped the
american cause at all but it was
empathize as opposed to sympathize same
thing with bush people were shocked when
i did the bush movie they said how can
you be in any way uh
anyway receptive to this guy that's
wrong
dramatists don't have political
positions they walk in the shoes of
that's why bush movie perhaps was
surprising to me and many people didn't
care for it
maybe that's what
but that's you've got to go there
no you if you did a movie about a
villain you have to go there
you have to
walk in their shoes yes so see them
because they usually villains usually
see themselves as the hero yes
so you have to
consider what is it like to live in a
world where
this person is the hero yes
is that a burden
is that hard not for george w bush
he's bitching because they didn't
understand them
but he had a good vision he said of
democracy and
you know democracy
forgives a lot of sins
you